Remember, in case you've forgotten, because
I rarely mention it.
We are a program mostly funded and supported
by members who sign up at Join Pacman dot
com.
Consider yourself invited.
Go to join Pacman dot com.
Grab a membership of both Joe Biden and Kamala
Harris had very solid appearances in interviews
and press conferences over the weekend.
I'm going to talk about it.
Many of you have been saying, David, you know,
as important it is as it is to expose the
insanity of Trump.
Now that we have a ticket, including not just
the presidential nominee, but also a vice
presidential nominee, let's highlight what
they are doing and the contrast of sanity
that they bring to the table.
And that's exactly what we're going to do.
Let's start with V.P. nominee Kamala Harris.
Kamala Harris was interviewed by CNN's Dana
Bash.
This is one of the first major interviews
that Kamala Harris did.
And I know that the bar is so low because
of Donald Trump and Mike Pence.
But Kamala Harris was coherent.
She met that low bar.
She answered the questions she was asked.
That's a higher bar for elected officials
who often don't even answer the questions
that they are asked.
And she precisely and accurately expanded
on each question to expose the pathetic failings
of the Trump administration.
She's not as far left as I am.
Kamala Harris.
But it would be a serious breath of fresh
air just to have people who can speak and
interact coherently in a position of power.
After the last four years.
But Kamala Harris does more than that.
She actually put on a clinic in terms of how
to be interviewed and how to answer questions,
not dodging, but answering and then doing
more.
So we're going to look at a few clips of this
and the context I would be thinking about
as you watch.
The one I was thinking about is how is Mike
Pence going to handle Kamala Harris during
the upcoming debate?
And I'm going to tell you a little bit later
on when that debate will be happening in sort
of the details of it.
First clip.
Dana Bash asks whether the economic recovery,
albeit slow, is a threat to Biden.
Harris, because as the economy improves, it
could pull people back over to Donald Trump.
And Kamala Harris very quickly gets to the
heart of the issue, which is this is a pandemic.
You can't just go around sacrificing whatever
or whoever you need to in order to temporarily
improve jobs numbers.
Take a look at her answer on the economy.
We have new job numbers out at the end of
the week, show that unemployment is at eight
point four percent and not great, but about
where President Obama had it in 2012.
And so my question is, are you worried, despite
the fact that it's, again, not great, that
things are coming back to the point where
where Donald Trump could have more meat on
the bone for his economic argument that it's
coming back?
Listen, I want the American people to be able
to work.
I want that we have jobs that are filled by
the hardworking people who want to work and
want to have the dignity that comes with good
work.
But there is no question that Donald Trump
has been an abject failure and incompetent
when it comes to addressing the severe job
loss that has happened as a result of the
pandemic because he has failed to address
the pandemic itself.
And when we look at this path, hopefully at
some point to recovery, his perspective cannot
be our perspective because his perspective
for too long is to talk about how well the
economy is doing based on how rich people
are doing.
We need to talk about how the economy is doing
based on how working people are doing.
And right now, working people are suffering.
People are standing or sitting in their cars
and food lines for hours.
What I like about this is that Kamala Harris
won't allow the conversation to simply be
about the unemployment rate is now coming
down or stocks are up or we are getting jobs
back that we lost.
She points out that's garbage.
It ignores why we are here.
And that's the big picture that Kamala Harris,
I hope, is going to be able to utilize and
exposed during the debate with Mike Pence.
So if she does this with the Pence debate,
any time that Mike Pence points out, you know,
August saw some of the best new jobs numbers,
she needs to point out not only is a partial
recovery of what we lost.
Not that good.
All of it is much worse because of the failed
handling of Corona virus.
Then the topic that comes up is foreign interference.
And I like what Kamala Harris does here in
that she is asked about Russia.
Do you believe Russia's meddling?
And we know.
Oh, that there are some people who reject
that idea, despite the fact that Mueller confirmed
it.
The Senate select report confirmed, OK, etc.,
There are some people who have sort of like
a visceral reaction anytime, sometimes mentions
Russia.
They think it's a conspiracy theory.
And I like what Kamala Harris does, which
she acknowledges that, of course, Russia is
doing this, but she immediately points to
the domestic voter suppression that the Trump
administration is engaged in and won't allow
the story or the question to only be, do you
believe Russia or not?
She knows that just dealing with that could
be a turnoff to some viewers.
And she says Trump is suppressing the vote.
Take a look at this, Russia.
The Department of Homeland Security bulletin
said that Russia is trying to amplify, amplify
claims that mail in voting will lead to widespread
voting fraud and undermine the public's trust
and the upcoming election.
Are you worried that Russian interference
could cost you the election?
I am clear that Russia interfered in the election
of president of the United States in 2016.
I served on the Senate Intelligence Committee.
We have published detailed reports about exactly
what we believe happened.
And and I do believe that there will be foreign
interference in the 2020 election and that
Russia will be at the front of the line.
Could it cost you the White House?
Theoretically, of course, yes.
And that's based on what you're hearing publicly
or you mentioned you're on this side.
Let me just say something.
We have to be a realist and I'm a realist
about it.
Does a realist about it.
We have classic voter suppression at play
in this election coming up, where after the
Supreme Court gutted the Voting Rights Act,
which Shelby v. Holder in 2013, dozens of
states passed laws that were designed to suppress
the black vote, to suppress students from
voting, to suppress our indigenous people
from support from voting.
So much so that in North Carolina, Court of
Appeals said it was the law was passed with
surgical precision to get in the way of black
voters from voting.
This is a good focus point.
This is a smart thing to focus on because
the idea of the current administration suppressing
the vote is going to be much more universally
compelling than an adjudication of.
To what degree do you believe Russia is doing
this or doing that?
And what?
Again, what I really like about this interview
is Kamala Harris answers every question.
She doesn't dodge the question, but then she
expands with proper context.
It's classic interview and media training.
Answer the question and then expand the framing.
Barack Obama was excellent at doing this.
On the first question about the economy.
Notice, she was asked, what about these improving
job numbers?
And she said, well, improving relative to
the worst numbers we've ever had.
And overall, much worse because of Trump's
failed response.
That's how you answer a question here.
Do you believe Russian meddling?
Yeah, I believe Russia will medal.
And this is way bigger because we've got domestic
voter suppression, purging of votes, voters
in disproportionately black areas and on and
on.
This is how you actually deal with issues
in interviews.
Now, one more clip.
And I encourage you to check out the full
interview, Kamala Harris, on whether she would
trust a corona virus vaccine endorsed by Donald
Trump.
This is crucial.
We know that Trump CDC sent out a letter saying
be ready for a vaccine at the end of October
or early November.
She has to be careful here.
Kamala Harris does, because anytime you say
you won't trust the vaccine, you're starting
to dabble in maybe being associated with anti
vaccine prism.
And that's not what this is about.
This is not about do we trust vaccines in
general due back vaccines work in general.
It's is Trump, for political reasons, going
to try to force something that's just not
yet ready.
Kamala Harris does a perfect job of refocusing
the question.
I missed a corona virus vaccine by the end
of the year or maybe sooner.
Would you trust that vaccine?
I think that we have learned since this pandemic
started, but really before that, that there's
very little that we can trust that comes out
of Donald Trump's mouth.
From the beginning of this pandemic, he has
called it a hoax.
His muzzle, the public health experts, he
has minimized the seriousness of it.
He has created false expectations for the
American people and American families, even
though if he had listened to the scientists
and the experts, he would have understood
the gravity of it and the power that he has.
President, United States has to actually save
lives.
And none of those were his priorities.
His priority was to to do whatever he thought
was politically expedient.
And so, no, I would not trust his word.
I would trust sort of public health experts
and scientists, but not Donald Trump.
This is really a clinic on how to answer.
It's not.
I do or don't trust the vaccine.
It's I don't make a decision on whether the
vaccine is okay on Trump's word because Trump
is unreliable.
It's not about vaccines being the problem
and getting into maybe always is.
She may be against vaccines.
No, it's about I don't trust Trump's word
on anything.
And as a media literacy person, as a fan of
the techniques of interviewing and being interviewed,
this is really well done by Kamala Harris.
I am very much looking forward to the V.P.
debate, which we'll talk about a little bit
later.